[Music]
big election the other day oh that's
right yeah
and uh
not everybody's happy a lot of people
still coming to grips with mitt romney's
loss
yeah yeah this is a true story i'm not
making this up it was reported just
reported that the morning after the
election mitt romney's family gathered
to share a gallon of chocolate milk
that's true
yeah in other words they took it much
harder than we thought they really
that is the lamest episode ever of
intervention
you gotta lay off the chocolate nuke
that's what they did for real
that's what they let off steam in there
you know how to party yeah
holiday season upon us you excited about
that holidays are coming up yeah
let's see it's uh
it's two weeks until thanksgiving seven
weeks until christmas and 14 weeks
before they're done counting votes in
florida
can you believe that they are still
counting votes in florida as of now yeah
they're still counting votes even though
the election is no longer in doubt and
the people who cast them are no longer
living
hey what oh oh
come
[Music]
oh
on
that character had a long life
voted and then
out the door
uh let's see some changes are expected
in the obama administration secretary of
state hillary clinton is likely to step
down
yeah
when he heard about it bill clinton said
that's great just give me a heads up
when she's on her way home
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he shoot away three people right in my
scenario
you gotta get out of here
taco bell in the news taco bell is gonna
start selling nachos and chicken nuggets
wrapped in a tortilla
yeah
in other words thank god we're going to
keep obamacare
we're all yeah
we're opening
[Music]
[Applause]
people dying left and right in my
monologue
hey uh a company i can't believe this a
company has issued a credit card that is
made of pure gold and embedded with 26
diamonds
even stranger it's a chevron gas card
you just swipe it and then fill up
honey boo boo in the news she's always
in the news now yeah
yeah a representative from peta has
written honey boo boo a letter urging
her not to eat her new pet chicken
so instead honey boo boo's mom ate the
representative from peta
[Music]
that's more debt more death yeah this
one cannibal i don't know how you feel
about this new condom law here in los
angeles as a result of a new law
requiring condoms the porn industry
may move out of los angeles according to
porn star james dean
yeah
now just to clarify jimmy dean is the
sausage guy
james dean is the other sausage guy
so that works it's just yeah
[Music]
yeah i feel pretty good yeah
it's true though the uh the porn
industry is angry about a new law
requiring condoms and they really are
threatening to leave los angeles the
entire porn industry yeah
well let me tell you something porn
you can leave los angeles but you can
never leave my hard drive
[Applause]
[Music]
or i can do it this way too and this is
you get to be my wife in this scenario
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's my currently caught watching porn
laughs
[Applause]